this training is so loathsome on every
level that even with her last name
voters Wyoming rejected her in the
Republican primary recently so she's out
but she's got a couple more months in
Congress and she's spending her time not
helping the state she supposedly
represents but attacking Kerry Lake in
Arizona
so
Cheney is so obsessed with Carrie Lake
that she cut an ad against her watch
this
I don't know that I have ever voted for
a Democrat but if I lived in Arizona I
absolutely would you have a candidate
for governor Carrie Lake you have a
candidate for Secretary of State Mark
fincham both of whom have said that they
will only honor the results of an
election if they agree with it and if
you care about the survival of our
Republic we cannot give people power who
will not honor elections
I've never voted for a Democrat well of
course Liz Cheney is a left-wing
Democrat let's stop lying so in response
to that ad Carrie Lake wrote this letter
to Liz Cheney begins quote dear Liz
thank you for your generous in-kind
contribution to my campaign your recent
TV ad urging arizonans not to vote for
me is doing just the opposite our
campaign donations are skyrocketing and
our website nearly crashed from the
traffic Carrie lake is running for
governor of Arizona as noted she joins
us tonight Kerry thanks so much for
coming on is that true
that's true Liz Cheney now is my
officially my biggest fundraiser to date
we've raised a half a million dollars
since she did the anti-endorsement and
people are still flocking to our website
kerrylake.com and donating it's been an
incredible Boom for us in fundraising so
I got to extend a big thank you to Liz
and at this rate Tucker we might have to
invite her to our inaugural ball because
we're gonna have to thank her for uh
bringing in so much fundraising money
for us well but you'd think it's a
little weird since she is a
congresswoman still from Wyoming she's
got a lot of hobbies she could be
planning a new invasion of Somalia or
something but she's attacking you she's
very focused on you why why is that do
you think
well I think the same reason I'm being
attacked by the media I'm speaking the
truth I mean you talked about it in your
monologue tonight we can't talk about
all these issues because the media has
told us it's they're prohibited you know
you can't talk about vaccines you can't
talk about elections you can't talk
about Paul Pelosi and now you can't talk
about Nancy Pelosi and you can't talk
about the elections and you can't talk
about uh covid and and I'm talking about
all those things because I still believe
we have a little bit of the First
Amendment left but I'm dangerous to
people like Liz Cheney and and the folks
that she hangs out with and they want to
stop people like me words are powerful I
I will say the left Liz Cheney for
example they understand that so I want
to ask your reaction to this story so
recently the headquarters for Katie
Hobbs that's the person you're running
against in the governor's race will not
debate you was vandalized the suspect
broke in and stole a few things the
suspect's name is Daniel Moda dos Reyes
and reportedly he's an illegal immigrant
to this country what's your reaction to
that story
he's currently in this country illegally
and I had heard that as well but you
know you can't say that now because you
can't talk about that it's insensitive
and the Press won't report that and I'm
glad that you just said that because
that's right he is currently in this
country illegally just like it sounds
like we've had many other instances
where people are here illegally and the
reporters never even asked that because
it proves the point that having a wide
open border means more crime a higher
incidence of crime for American citizens
and that's what we're seeing here in
Arizona and you talked about the
homeless man that was found you know
half naked in Pelosi's home this is why
Republicans have ideas to stop these
problems I have a homeless policy the
Press doesn't want to talk about that I
have a policy to work to end chronic
Street homelessness get people help get
them off the streets and return quality
of life for the hard-working people of
Arizona but the Press would either
rather act like there's been some
Watergate break-in at my opponent's
office I don't even know where her
office is by the way I assumed it was in
a basement somewhere they'd rather cover
that and make up lies than cover our
policies which will actually help the
people of Arizona and make them safer
the Press has gone bad and the people
are awake to it
the fact that even runs someone as lame
as Katie Hobbs for governor of a major
State tells you that they believe they
have the system wired they think they
can't lose I mean why wouldn't they pick
someone who can talk
[Laughter]
well her sister her twin sister actually
there was some undercover video of her
the other day saying that she voted for
me and I was listening to her in that
undercover video and she could actually
communicate a little better and I
thought well she's obviously smarter if
she voted for me and she can obviously
articulate some points why didn't they
run her twin sister instead of Katie who
can't seem to articulate even her
policies before the people of Arizona in
a debate it's almost sad Carrie like
joining us tonight thank you very much
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight